[Music]
joining me today is an author the
co-founder and president of
environmental progress org and a
candidate to be the next governor of the
great state of California
Mike Shellenberger welcome to the Rubin
report having me David
I am very jealous of your beard even the
amount of gray I just added up before I
came yeah do the reverse what do they do
it's just for men yeah takes the gray
out exactly you do yeah I'm trying to
the baby boomer votes so you know
Addison gray in yeah yeah I'm very
excited to talk to you because I think
this is going to be a good political
discussion but also we'll get to some
environmental stuff that I wanted to
touch on and a little bit about this
state of California this highly
regulated highly taxed state that we're
in and all kinds of stuff but first you
live in Berkeley I do what the hell is
going really what's going on there it
seems like it's become one you know it
was once the the home for free speech
mm-hm and and real liberalism and it
seems like it's become this sort of
hysterical crazy silencing mob up there
what's happening I mean in some ways
it's funny because it's it's supposed to
be an outlier but in some ways it's
similar of what's happening in the rest
of the country Lauren don't listen to
each other you know it's so striking I
think that the social media gives people
a lot of confidence in their views they
have a lot of information available to
them and so people are just not
listening and I find that everywhere you
know Berkeley is certainly the case
we've been smug for a long time though
we pioneered it but have you seen a
change let's say in the last five or ten
years has something actually changed or
was this all just sort of what's
happening nationally I mean when I when
I sort of changed my views in particular
of nuclear and dealt with some of the
backlash against that that gave me a
different point of view on the broader
kind of culture and the ways in which
people are intolerant I don't want to
hear it but you know just because of my
age I think and I hadn't been associated
with the University I had a think tank
in Oakland lived in Berkeley but I
hadn't really had a lot of interaction
with the students until recently so I
didn't even know about trigger warnings
like until like a couple years ago then
I was like what are those yeah so live
in
we had a think tank in Oakland I'm just
trying to paint for the people that
don't know yeah you know you come from a
lefty area and all that stuff yeah so
before we get into the nuclear stuff
which is really I think your your key
thing yeah tell me that just a little
bit about your history what do I need to
know about you before we get on the meat
here let's see so I'm a gen Xer born
1971 raised you know in that fear of the
Cold War as you probably had you know
saw the day after on television when I
was in whatever 12 you know terrified of
nuclear war my parents were Christian
pacifists but they also divorced I was
kid of divorce
suburban Colorado very left-wing kid you
know at very my parents were pretty
liberal and then I moved to the Bay Area
after college to work with a left-wing
activist group called global exchange so
it was always I've always been sort of a
man of the left and when my views of
nuclear in particular change in the
environment then I sort of was able to
kind of start to get myself permission
to rethink other things and not not
believe everything I thought so to speak
and to start to question some of those
things yeah and that's why I thought
you'd be a perfect guess because what
we're about to talk about now you're
sort of evolution and yeah you're
pushing against and where you get
support it sort of fits a lot of sort of
we're on that and what a lot of what
some of my other guests have dealt with
right so tell me as you woke up to
nuclear like all right so what was the
sort of base environmental thinking when
you just got out of college and we're
working and yeah yeah I mean I had sort
of that sort of basic simplistic you
know kind of lefty view that all of the
problems in the world world do to big
corporations and capitalism and that
that's what was wrong with the
environment and I had this picture I
think that a lot people have still which
is that a more beautiful world would be
solar panels on your roof and electric
car in the driveway and and we wrote
about how to achieve that but the more
we were writing about it the more we
realized the limitations of solar and
wind in particular its energy sources
and we had a bunch of friends who were
just like you know if you're concerned
about climate change and air pollution
why not nuclear and we had to go through
a process really took several years to
sort of finally answer that question and
go yeah we got to have nuclear if we're
gonna deal with climate
so before we fully get there what are
some of the limitations because I think
most people even now even yeah you're
saying this was a couple years ago for
you sure but now most people I think
have that idea if we just all had solar
panels on our roof and if you know if we
had more wind turbines and all that that
everything actually would be okay but
that's actually not what you argue
that's right and it's in and my views
sort of have evolved but I mean the
biggest problem people are aware of is
that you only get electricity out of
wind and solar when the sun is shining
and the wind is blowing and people kind
of go well maybe there the sun is
shining when the winds not blowing in
other way and it's like no that's not
really true either so you always have to
have power plants ready to run at any
minute
usually natural gas because you can fire
them up so quickly in people go what
about batteries batteries are really
expensive just getting enough of them to
store the amount electricity you need I
mean think we had we calculated that if
you took all of the batteries in
California and you stored all of
electricity we'd have like a couple
hours max you know so and that would be
taking all the batteries out of cars and
trucks so it's a lot of it's a lot of
batteries yeah oh these batteries are
terrible for the environment and there's
another problem with renewables which is
that they take a lot of space because
the sunlight and water and wind our
energy diffuse there's just you have to
get a lot of wind to get enough
electricity out of them or you have to
cover a lot of area to get enough
concentrated sunlight to make sufficient
clients electricity you actually have
big land-use impacts and if the whole
point is to save the natural environment
you end up doing things like killing a
lot of desert tortoises in the Mojave
and then you have a big waste problem
that we haven't solved both solar panels
and batteries contain high levels of
toxic waste in fact about two to three
hundred more toxic wastes from the same
amount of energy in solar panels than is
created from nuclear Wow
so when you kind of it's really the big
problems with renewables are actually
environmental problems yeah and it also
tends to make them more expensive them
do you do you think then that there's no
place for them or is there some place
like if you were to derive from from LA
here if we were to drive towards like
Palm Springs there are in the hills you
see plenty of wind turbines yeah
obviously here in LA because of the
amount of sunshine we see plenty of
people with solar panels
Rufe every time I go to Home Depot
there's a little five people that try to
accost me and get me unsure panels and
all that do you think there's any place
for those things oh sure and there's
there's one place for them ISM in my
backyard I have you know I mean I think
that solar was traditionally used for
remote applications so places where you
don't have electrical wire doesn't make
sense to have electrical wire there
solar panels are really cool
technologies I mean just there's nothing
wrong with them I think there's
something wrong when we are subsidizing
the most affluent members of our society
to have and that's what's happened so
California has seen our electricity
prices went up 40 percent at a period
where I'm sure they went up four times
more than they did in the rest of the
country over the last seven years and a
big part of that was we were subsidizing
people to get solar and wind I think if
you're doing some experimental work some
R&D perfectly important role for the
government that's how we got jet
turbines and a lot of the technologies
and our iPhones but when you're kind of
constantly subsidizing them the people
that get punished is working people you
know middle-class people poor people
because their electricity prices go up
and so that that starts to have a
concern that a universal concern whether
you're liberal or conservative or yeah
so I want to get a little more to that
bedroom it's rolling whether that's the
answer will show that for now but I'm
very much aware of that because even
right now as I've looked into it a
little bit you know I see that a lot of
subsidies have actually run out in
California there's a lot that are
expiring at the end of the year and all
sorts of other stuff and also just by a
function of having this studio I mean
you see all these lights like these
lights they burn hot and they suck a ton
of of electricity so my electricity
bills there are are crazy surprises
something I'm very aware of so Johnny
tell me when you started realizing that
nuclear wasn't the the evil thing that
perhaps it had been portrayed as you
know I I think I I mean I helped to stop
a proposed radioactive waste repository
actually in my late 20s but as you got
concerned about climate you started
hearing people talk a little bit more
about it I think my views were probably
softening even before I became directly
focused on it but then it was really a
couple of friends one of them was
Stewart Brand who was sort of the
original hippie you know Whole Earth
Catalog advisor to Governor Brown in the
70s he
wrote a famous essay in 2005 and in a
book in 2009 and by the time I read the
book in 2009 I was pretty persuaded
because he just went through all the
evidence you know the accidents really
were not what people think they are the
waste is actually the best kind of waste
because there's hardly any of it it's
easy to manage never hurts anybody what
do they do with the waste because I
think that yeah that's what we usually
think of our I of the nuclear power
plant in the Simpsons and the three is
more damage for your argument though
yeah yeah yeah the first thing you learn
is you go await the waste isn't green
and liquid because it was in the
Simpsons which is how I got my
information um yeah mr. burns was
running for governor which oh yeah a
little bit more money than I got you
know being right now what we do with it
is fine I think we take it you take the
spent fuel you take the fuel rods out of
the nuclear reactor you cool them in
water for a few years and then we put
them in dry cask storage right there on
the site where the plant is from an
environmental point of view that's like
exactly what you'd want I mean if you
when you grow up kind of learning about
the environment the first thing you
learn is that waste always has to go
somewhere right it doesn't disappear and
you have to be responsible for taking
care of the waste products from our
consumption
so that's nuclear is like the only way
that we make electricity that does that
right now we don't have any protections
that solar panels won't just go into
landfills and leach toxic chemicals or
be sent to Bangladesh to be torn apart
by kids and slums only nuclear really
cares for its waste and it's all in a
really clinical way we put them in these
big casts and and they're right there on
basically a couple of basketball courts
at a given plant and we kind of look at
them and store them and watch on a pill
go what if they leak or something there
in these hugely thick cast but even if
they were you would be able to see it
and observe it and there's not really
anything to leak because there's no way
is there any evidence that something
could really go awry with that as you're
laying it out is something that's pretty
safe no there's no evidence that waste
from nuclear energy production has had
any of those problems who will say pool
point to problems with the waste that
came out of weapons production but that
that is a very different process you're
just creating huge amounts of plutonium
having a cheery neum for bombs and when
we were really when you had really big
problems even there it was like in the
middle of World War two
where you're just throwing bodies and
machines to fight this war so it's got
an incredibly good track record I mean
people will talk about wanting to bury
it under the desert in Nevada and I'm
always like I don't know why like why do
you need to do that like just it's fine
where it is you just store it and
maintain it it takes up no space it
doesn't pose any harm for me I'm like
that's like the one of the Chiefs
selling points of nuclear is the way it
manages this waste yeah so when they
talk about that you know burying it in
the desert somewhere on Iran or whatever
are they talking more about the
weapons-grade way no they're talking
about the nuclear energy waste and I try
to figure it out because I'm like a bit
of a newcomer to it I didn't you know
I'm just I'm I ask people in the
industry why do you need to do that and
they kind of go well because it's better
because it's better look who made a lot
of money building that big hole in
Nevada you know being from a libertarian
point of view you kind of go there's
just there was a lot of money to be made
on these fears that were manufactured
and that were used to manipulate people
like us a group in the 70s so you would
think that there's some relationship
between like a bomb going off and the
waste and there's just nothing the waste
can't be used in that way so I have to
say it's one of the things I find most
frustrating and baffling you know is it
also one of those things that you really
and this is why I want to tag on the
show to really unpack this stuff you
really have to have some basic
understanding of how this all works so
when you even mentioned before that the
the different ways between weapons-grade
yeah and just you know civilian use for
power I don't think people have any
sense that these are different things
right they don't and the funny thing is
so I'm working on a I've got a book that
I'm gonna I'm doing on the history of
nuclear and one of the surprising things
is that ordinary folks knew that there
was a big difference between nuclear
weapons and nuclear power plants from
like the mid 50's to like the mid 70s
like people kind of in fact the whole
people were actually excited about
nuclear power like they were like this
is great you mean like this thing that's
really terrible and frightening actually
has this really positive side and I was
like yeah well let's get some of that
positive side going
cuz all we hear about is a negative
stuff this makes sense I was born in 76
so right when they did probably yeah and
then Three Mile Island accident occurred
and blown way out of proportion but
really importantly China Syndrome this
this anti-nuclear movie in 1979 came out
and that really shaped perceptions and
and that they deliberately and that you
can see what they're dealing constantly
they were trying to mix up the two
things same word yeah you know but you
know it's funny because we have a lot of
dangerous things in our society that we
actually use for positive things we're
even injecting poliovirus into people's
brains to kill cancer particular kind of
cancers you know we obviously immunize
that we inject our children with
dangerous diseases because to protect
them so I think we're capable of having
a more complex understanding of that
technology but there is vested interests
and ideological interests in maintaining
people's fears right so there's sort of
two separate things here there's one is
what the reality is and then there's the
other where when you hear about Three
Mile Island or Chernobyl or any of this
stuff what's the argument that your your
best argument when there's something
that actually is a disaster in the case
of Chernobyl I guess you're saying
three-mile
not as bad as they hyped it up to be
yeah so I mean there's three serious
accidents that involved melted reactors
Three Mile Island Chernobyl and
Fukushima the worst was Chernobyl and
even the worst one killed shockingly few
people basically killed the firefighters
who put out the fire about 50 to date
and you know firefighters died putting
out fires you know so it's not like
unique to nuclear accidents there were
there's about a 1% mortality for the
several thousand people that got thyroid
cancer and then that's it like no
increase in any other cancers so nothing
else nothing else if you would have
asked me just yeah knowing anything
about this I think I probably would have
said oh there's probably like some sort
of even generational thing going no
definitely I think that's I think that's
really the yeah the meme that's out
there that's the one that they even
promoted a lot was that somehow they
were yet exposed to radiation then your
kids would have some problems and we
don't see that and that's great I mean
it's one of those things where everyone
should have been like yay like like yay
we discovered that nobody was
let's celebrate but people were like no
there's got to be something wrong I mean
I think there's also just it is such a
different way of making heat that's what
nuclear plants do they make heat and
then the heats used to make electricity
but there's no smoke and there's no fire
there's no smoke and that's just weird I
mean humans have been around for over
10,000 years and we really evolved and
are in our pre-human ancestors helped to
make us with fire so fire is just a
central part of human stories around the
world and it's a part of our identity I
mean look at the Greek myths and then we
have this completely different way of
making energy and power and fire and I
just think and not fire energy and power
and and we kind of go it's strange and I
think we kind of go there's got to be
something wrong with it and of course
you know you get really close to nuclear
reactors it's really dangerous harmful
and you can die so it's not like it's
harmless but I think people don't
understand you know when you consider
that you know somewhere between 5 and 7
million people will die every year from
just breathing smoke and suffering
respiratory illnesses I think we just
are less scared of smoke then then we
should be here
there's something about nuclear power
and when when you relate it to weapons
in our minds it's become like this thing
where we love disaster movies you know
like all of this stuff so it's sort of
taken a life unto its own in a way yeah
yeah it's such an interesting problem
because my money had people like they
want so much safety from nuclear even
though it like kills like basically
nobody you know compared to like every
other way of making energy I mean
natural gas pipelines explode all the
time oil refiners go down and it's kind
of like come on you know you drive your
car super fast you smoke cigarettes when
you get you when you drink too much you
know yeah we do all these risky
behaviors and somehow we don't want any
risky behavior from this one I think it
is that Association you think something
horribly could go wrong even though
we've seen horrible things go wrong with
nuclear accidents and it doesn't harm
our Laney buddy so you know I think it's
about a lot of different things you know
I also it was interesting I saw you I
was watching one of your earlier
conversations where one of your guests
talked about the infantilization of the
public you know me here we're rich and
comfortable and where we want like high
levels of safety I think the other thing
that happens as we've become developed
civilization is that our fantasies of
what could go wrong get even more crazy
right like you know I mean just the
crazy things that people thought about
with genetically modified foods you know
these just kind of scenarios that we
concoct it's different from what it was
100 years ago I mean when you're trying
to deal with a cholera epidemic or a
polio epidemic you're not you don't need
to fantasize about horrible things going
wrong you're watching them happen yeah
it's interesting I'm not gonna remember
this story totally correctly so I have a
feeling you'll be able to clean it up
but I grew up in Long Island and there
was a power plant the either that was
coming or that they wanted to movers
like Indian Point does that sound right
as sure um yeah in Shoreham they were
they wanted to build the Shoreham one
they did finish the Indian point one
okay so yeah I remember just around that
all that I think I was maybe around 12
or something yeah and I remember hearing
about it all the time and that's when
the phrase NIMBY got in my head you know
not in my backyard yeah just this
endless hysteria that people were
talking about that you know we're all
gonna have you know tumors growing out
of our head and all this craziness and
yeah I guess you're saying there's no
evidence for any of that no and you know
it's always like those panics that occur
and I think you have to consider it as a
panic it's always about something else
you know there's something going on in
the society I mean the people that it's
not everybody that was equally afraid of
nuclear plants right it's a particular
people that have particular views of the
world and there are suspicious of the
government suspicious of corporations
and the system suspicious of modern life
and so they're the ones who are more
prone to have those kinds of fears I
think we see something different on the
conservative side the political right
they have different fears you know that
and if they express themselves
differently yeah so okay so when you
start having this sort of wake up to
nuclear and you're in this pretty lefty
field in the geographic places that yeah
and what kind of pushback did you get Oh
a lot I mean a lot I mean and it's and
it's continued although I have to say
it's gotten a lot better I mean we saw
one of the big environmental online
magazines just came out with a long
article in support of nuclear the I was
in a documentary film that came out of
2013 so it's been now you know five
years almost and that's how long these
things take for people to kind of calm
down and
the evidence and you just get up every
morning and you continue to advocate and
and people you know facts still matter
you know I mean do they matter yeah I
think they do I mean I think it I think
you still need time there's a way in
which like facts matter more than ever
because there's so much opinion out
there everyone's got an opinion but you
know real facts you kind of go look it's
the World Health Organization like do
you think there's a conspiracy involving
thousands of scientists to cover up some
deaths that occurred I mean it just
doesn't really make sense for most
people there's a lot of easily a lot of
conspiracy theorists and crazy ideas but
I think that a lot of people have come
around on the issue yeah so a lot of my
former guests have been progressives
that have sort of had a kind of
awakening and then they end up being
hated by the very people they were with
were you getting that like oh yeah I'm
sure you were getting pushback on the
intellectual ideas just I just want to
sort of understand because I think my
legs are attuned to this when you start
doing something a little bit different I
just want to understand sort of the
level of hate and push back you're
getting yeah it's hard I mean you know
you get a lot of I mean you support to
remind yourself that sort of not about
you you know because you take it
personally yeah you're like well I'm not
that kind of a person you know and
there's like oh they're just projecting
stuff onto you you know the most painful
stuff was when I had a friend on my
Facebook page accused me of being on the
take from the nuclear industry and I was
just kind of like look dude the
friendship is like over you know it was
like that's but I and he apologized
later but it was an interesting
interaction because it was kind of like
hey man you really kind of let yourself
forget who your friend was you know in
this kind of you knows in the midst of
all the Bernie Sanders stuff or Bernie
was attacking nuclear and he was a big
Bernie guy and I just remember being
like you don't you're just caught up in
something and and actually you need to
kind of take us take a minute and get
control and think about what you're
saying and who you're saying it to yeah
and he apologized for it but I was kind
of like how do you do that at like a
mass level where you kind of go hey
everybody can we just you know deep
breath yeah take a deep breath I mean
yeah I love hearing that personal side
of it because I think so many people are
going through that not necessarily with
with nuclear power like you're going
through it but just with whatever their
own political evolution is so let's talk
about Bernie in this for a little bit
because yeah
he was campaigning against this now if
this if the science is as clean as what
you're saying is then why wouldn't the
progressive you know lefty guy who's
always talking about he's talking about
and what does he say an environmental
revolution right he wants a social
revolution and any yeah political
revolution in environmental he wants
environmental justice I don't even know
what that means
but why wouldn't he be free that that's
a very interesting question and I
suspect there's a lot of different
reasons I mean some of it is he's an old
guy you know it's very hard for old
people to change it was hard for me to
change my mind about nuclear and I was
in my leg like late 30s you know early
40s and again you have to overcome a
whole bunch of associations you know
there's basically a picture a lot of
what gets called environmentalism
doesn't have any do with the environment
it has more to do with the kind of
society you want and so the idea would
be we should have decentralized food and
energy production you know we're all
gonna have our own little chicken coop
and our own little garden you're part of
it my chicks aren't laying yet they're
like 18 weeks right now yeah yeah you
know I can yeah I mean we you know we
have a little guard in the back and like
the amount of money and labor we put
into that garden I'm like each tomato is
like $500 you know so you know it's a
bit of that fantasy I mean I you know I
love work in the garden right like it's
great to work in the garden it's great
to have fresh eggs and you know and and
and for people that can afford it and
you might want it it might be cool to
have solar panels for a variety of
different reasons I think that when you
kind of get too caught up in that and
you start to think that I'm gonna
produce all my food that way you know
we're Alma proves all my energy that way
you've really started to lose touch with
kind of a basic understanding of how you
know materials and energy and society
works and you're letting that desire for
a fantasy to take over so that's kind of
what we come up against I think that's
worry if you can kind of get people out
of their own life and their own like how
they want to live in their backyard -
well how are we gonna you know there's
like seven billion people on earth so
how are we going to provide food and
resources for everybody that helps to
recontextualize things yeah so what's
the connection there between what's the
disconnect I should say between sort of
progressivism
and using nuclear power because what
you're saying is this can bring more
energy to people at a lower cost and a
lot of the other things that we're using
at a state at a safer level and yet it
seems to me that even though yes
Bernie's an old guy it seems like this
is something he should should have come
around on so I'm still missing that
disconnect maybe maybe we just don't
know yeah there's something about the
way the left is with environmentalism
that's so connected now to solar yeah
and so and wind and stuff like that well
and it's funny cuz it all actually
happened here in California and you can
see the difference between our current
Governor Jerry Brown and his dad his dad
was governor and he was what the he was
the Democratic Party that I kind of was
raised on sick kids the party of the
people you know it was a party for the
working man the working family everyone
gets a high wage he built highways
agriculture factories the 60s occur his
son gets elected Jerry for the first
time 1974 takes power 1975 any any and
he says he's interviewed by William F
Buckley actually he says we all have to
do with less we need to have less
material consumption we have to obey
limits well as a striking thing to be to
hear from not just who he was as a
Democrat as someone that was up for
everybody prospering but it was also
he's one of the wealthiest families in
California they owned a huge oil
monopoly from the Indonesian military
dictatorship so who was the one who were
the people that were promoting this idea
of doing with less it was the wealthiest
members of our society it was often kids
that inherited you know family wealth
they had land and so one of the most
surprising things ran for governor as I
learned more about the state is our
housing crisis is a direct consequence
of that same worldview that took over
left liberal politics in the 70s before
that the idea was there should be
abundant housing people should be able
to buy a home and home ownership was
really very progressive right because
homeowners have so much wealth in their
homes and progressives wanted to promote
that well Jerry Brown gets in and his
anti development you know so-called
environmentalists get in there and they
seek to restrict homes housing
and energy and it was a almost like it
was like almost like a opposite of what
came before it so you're telling me that
first term Jerry Brown is the guy I have
to blame for the mortgage that I'm gonna
be paying for the rest of my life on
this thing yeah I mean and really the I
mean he's now it sort of four terms and
he leaves office at the end of this year
and all right at the beginning of next
year I should say and yeah I mean and
it's again you kind of go well then why
did Jer why was Jerry like that I mean
that's where in my book I kind of you
kind of are like searching for it and I
think you just kind of get to a backlash
against basic progressive and liberalism
I mean that's the funny thing you get
there's a backlash against making
prosperity for all they didn't want
everybody to have prosperity they wanted
to really kick away the ladder and kind
of protect all of it for themselves
right so it's so interesting so you're
saying basically in 75 he's going well
we're gonna have to deal with less but
he didn't really mean we he meant know
because I'm in his oil guys and
obviously yeah the guys had a lot of
money and power for a long time through
his family because he's he's still
around picking some odd years later now
I want to talk a lot more about what why
you want to be governor yeah but one
other thing have you read that book
right there by a teaching of course oh
yes and I know Alex I had a coffee with
him yeah okay great so so Alex apps
night I had him on it's the the Kate of
the book the case the moral case for
fossil fuels right is the book I hit him
on probably about two years ago mhm I
don't think that I've ever gotten more
heat for an interview uh-huh then I mean
I've had plenty of controversial people
on yeah that I then get lumped in with
and people think I endorse all their
views which obviously yeah in sensical
but I truly think I got the most hate I
ever got this guy on deck is really sick
his basic argument is the title of the
book right he's just saying the most you
can do for humans now is to still use
fossil fuels mhm
I'm can curious where you kind of fall
on that argument I think he gets it half
right I mean my view is that it's very
mighty is very simple in some ways I
mean I think people I think now that I
know more about housing and schools and
other things I'm like oh that's really
complicated stuff but energy I think is
pretty simple so most of us start off in
societies using wood and dung as our
primary energy anything is better than
that including Bernie
Cole right because it's terrible you
breathe the smoke and and it's just the
labor involved right so then you get
electricity from coal and hydroelectric
dams those are the first thing poor
countries get so there's really a moral
case for for coal and hydro if all
you're using is wouldn't done but then I
also think there's a moral case for
using cleaner burning fuels like natural
gas and uranium so it so he wants to I
mean Alex did a good job of this book in
the sense that he wanted to start a
conversation about what are we to stop
poor countries from using fossil fuels
that's really unethical but I think you
should go the other step to say look
there's even if you don't worried about
climate there's air pollution there's
other impacts of fossil energy use and
if we've got this fantastic alternative
and usually we go from coal to natural
gas and then to uranium then we should
keep going you know it's energy
transitions and these energy transitions
which I don't I get too much of my
campaign but these energy a little bit
idea yeah yeah the energy transitions
you know when you go from a horse and
buggy to internal combustion engines and
trains are what drives those transitions
from energy sources so you go from wood
and dung to coal and part because of
trains but also factories and whatnot
and then I think you eventually get to a
electric powered world electric cars
electric heating um as we move towards
nuclear okay so we've hit then solar
we've hit wind let's just do two of the
others you mentioned one of them right
there so let's just talk about natural
gas yes what do we need to know about
natural gas I mean the first thing to
know is that just like on so many of the
things Americans are just the luckiest
people in the world I mean we have so
much oil and gas it's just incredible
like a huge amount of our wealth and
last decade came from this fracking
revolution which of course environmental
supposedly hate although in many ways
they really liked it yeah that was gonna
be my second way to ask you but I really
I'm really asking the same yeah right
yeah yeah so um you know I think there's
two things I think are important to know
about natural gas the first is that it's
just way better than coal like we went
looked at all the scientific
peer-reviewed research and it's just on
every measure water use water pollution
air pollution carbon emissions
everything gas is just better than coal
of course it is right you use in your
kitchen and it's safe
I mean it still explodes
sometimes kilcher want to talk about the
exploding yeah yeah yeah and it's not as
good as uranium which we used for
nuclear
similarly on all the same metrics
uranium performs better so there's a way
in which I just kind of go there's just
this is just basic energy density this
basic physical facts about these fuels
makes their makes a progression exist
wood to coal to oil to natural gas to
uranium I think I think it's important
to know and I think one of the
challenges I often make to my
libertarian friends is that the
government played a very positive role
in all of these energy technologies
maybe with the exception of of coal
although there's a little bit there but
you really oil and gas the US government
has constantly been supporting R&D
nuclear came out of a military weapons
program so I think that you know when
you think about these energy transitions
I think there is a role for government
because there is a public benefit in
terms of moving towards cleaner fuels
and also faster in better transportation
yeah so let's just do fracking 101 yes
sir because every time you say fracking
yeah people think of you know the fire
coming out of their faucet yeah yeah
they think of to make another Simpsons
reference they think of Burns's slant
oil drilling company they don't destroy
it Springfield
yeah yeah is that what fracking you know
the funny thing is the the sort of
famous fire the famous water faucet on
fire scene um we now I think we now
think came from a much older natural gas
well not from fracking and and the
fracking itself is just breaking up the
rock the shale rock and allowing the gas
to escape that's not the stuff you would
worry about if you care about the
environment what you worry about is the
disposal of the water and the the
sealing of the of the of the pipes where
the the gas comes out so the things
people tend to worry about or think
about I think you just got tied up with
the word fracking as well which sounds
like a bad word but the funny thing is
like like just like you know coal has
actually gotten cleaner over the years
natural gas has gotten cleaner over the
years oil burning cars everything is
cleaner and better but never as good as
that next cleaner energy source so the
better way to think about it I I think
is that we get caught up in like how do
you get
gasps and whatever you need to have some
protections of the environment on the
public but really the main event is to
move from these dirtier energy sources
to cleaner ones
[Music]